a selecciones del domingo se veían como
un termómetro al gobierno de lasso con
esto en mente qué tanta gobernabilidad
le queda
Hola Andrés Buenas noches sí
efectivamente los resultados del
referendo lo que muestra es un alto
rechazo al gobierno de Guillermo lasso
seis de cada diez rechazaron en teoría
una propuesta que iba a buscar una
respuesta a la crisis de seguridad a la
crisis también a nivel de lo que es el
sistema de Justicia la fiscalía pero que
finalmente tuvo un un alto rechazo eso
lo que deja es un gobierno debilitado
más debilitado de lo que ya estaba
porque recordemos que ya tenía un nivel
de aceptación bastante bajo algunas
encuestadoras le daban entre el 20 y 30%
recién va a cumplir dos años de su
gestión en los próximos dos meses y por
otro lado también se observa un
retroceso en la derecha liberal y
conservadora que eran los aliados en
naturales del gobierno de Guillermo
lasso que de hecho eh rompió sus
alianzas al inicio de su mandato mucho
antes de que fuera posesionado y que eso
también le ha generado problemas de
gobernabilidad principalmente en la
relación entre el ejecutivo y el
legislativo es decir la asamblea
nacional ahora de otro lado el banco JP
Morgan tilda panorama para lazo es muy
desafiante después de las elecciones y
que así su margen de maniobra será
limitado Cómo afecta todo esto a la
economía ecuatoriana puede haber un
déficit fiscal como lo pronostica JP
Morgan
Bueno creo que ahora el panorama es
bastante complicado porque Incluso se ha
levantado nuevamente esta la idea esta
propuesta de activar un mecanismo
constitucional que prevé está previsto
en la Constitución ecuatoriana que se
denomina la muerte Cruzada es decir que
la asamblea pueda destituir al
presidente y el presidente también tenga
que y también la asamblea es disuelta Es
decir hay una muerte Cruzada entre El
Ejecutivo y el legislativo para
reorganizar elecciones en los próximos
seis meses al inicio de eso era una
propuesta enfocada en una sola
organización política pero durante las
últimas horas esto se ha ampliado a
diferentes actores incluso actores muy
cercanos al oficialismo al gobierno
quienes en un análisis mucho más frío
del que ha sido el que ha realizado el
gobierno a nivel público muestran que el
capital político está bastante
desgastado y que esto podría generar
problemas en cuanto a las decisiones a
nivel económico social Las reformas
laborales del sistema de seguridad
social que estaban planteados en la
agenda legislativa Durante este año y
claramente eso va a tener un efecto en
cuanto a la seguridad jurídica del país
también en cuanto a tener un panorama
claro para los inversores dentro del
Ecuador y a eso se suma la crisis de
seguridad que también ha generado un
impacto tanto en la inversión privada
como también en el tema turístico señora
Andrade luego de las elecciones lazo
pidió un acuerdo nacional en un intento
por reunificar al país pero Correa le
exigió que declare la muerte Cruzada
como se lo explicaba que es decir que
disuelva el congreso y convoque a
elecciones anticipadas alegando que no
tiene representatividad ante los
resultados del domingo Qué puede ocurrir
primero la unión de Ecuador o la salida
de lazo Bueno creo que el contexto de
llamado de unidades bastante complejo
recordemos Que el mismo presidente lazo
como parte de su campaña para el
referéndum que que perdió
llamó a una polarización muy agresiva
calificando a quienes se ponían al
referendo como narco político como
socios de narcotráfico incluso los
calificó como antipatrias es decir
estaría Llamando a un acuerdo nacional
justamente con las personas que
rechazaron la propuesta del oficialismo
que les calificó de narcopolíticos de
narcotraficantes de apoyar al
narcotráfico y de antipatrias entonces
un poco contradictoria y muchas voces a
nivel político y social que ya se han
pronunciado en rechazo este acuerdo
nacional que lo califican como falso y
mentiroso porque no es la primera vez
que el gobierno hace este llamado
mencioné el acuerdo que hizo a nivel
legislativo Antes de posicionarse que lo
rompió pocas horas antes de de
producirse la elección de la presidencia
de la asamblea y de toda y De igual
forma Durante los últimos meses del
acuerdo que supuestamente se estaba
construyendo con las organizaciones del
movimiento indígena que tampoco
admitieron buenos resultados que
quedaron bastante satisfechos y que
todavía generan una conflictividad
social latente que puede reactivarse en
cualquier momento